welcome back to CBS this morning we
begin with breaking news and historic
day on Capitol Hill where the House of
Representatives is expected to formally
impeach the President of the United
States today this will be the only the
third time that the House lawmakers have
taken this extraordinary action in 230
years at around 10:30 this morning
Eastern Time
members will begin at least six hours of
debate on the two articles of
impeachment against President Trump the
house is expected to vote late in the
day and both articles are expected to
pass mostly along party lines one thing
to watch today the 31 Democrats from
districts the president won in 2016 only
two of them say they plan to vote
against impeachment they are Colin
Peterson of Minnesota chairman of the
House Agriculture Committee and jeff van
drew of New Jersey who says he'll switch
to the Republican Party after the vote
Democrat jared golden of Maine says
he'll vote for article 1 abuse of power
but against article 2 obstruction of
Congress CBS News legal analyst Jonathan
Turley and Kim Whaley join us now from
Washington Jonathan testified at the
request of House Republicans during a
judiciary committee hearing on the legal
standard for impeachment good morning to
both you Kim I want to start with you
and I'm hoping that you can clarify
something perplexing for me here the
Senate rules for impeachment say I do so
what I do solemnly swear this is the
oath that each senator takes I do
solemnly swear that in all things
pertaining to the trial of the
impeachment of blank I will do impartial
justice that is the oath and yet we have
a Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
saying publicly he's not impartial can
you scratch two things for me it's very
difficult he's also said this is really
about Republicans versus Democrats being
on Team red versus team blue but it
really is about the scope of the
Constitution whether there are
guardrails that are going to be enforced
for the per office of the presidency you
think about Simone biles going to the
Olympics and it's already been
predetermined how hard she works no
matter what she does she will not win a
medal that's basically what the Senate
majority leader is saying here and
we have to remember the impeachment
process is about the office of the
presidency not about the man it's easy
to get caught up in mr. Trump personally
but going forward we have to think about
what this does to the scope of power
that we are handing off to future
presidents and future generations and
that's what makes his comments I think
so troubling what impact do you think
Jonathan this could have on future
presidents picking up on Kim's point
well it's going to have a significant
impact and I think it'll be a largely
dysfunctional one the problem I have is
that this sets the standard quite low
for impeachment
you know they ultimately rejected the
four articles that I primarily testified
against including bribery and they went
with the two that I thought were
legitimate but they did not obviously
follow my advice and trying to build a
record to support those two counts or
articles and the problem I have is that
judging on how they define these two
articles you could impeach every living
president on this type of of allegations
the the most troubling for me is
obstruction of Congress they said in a
an abbreviated period for investigation
arguably the shortest investigation of
any presidential impeachment depending
on how you count the Johnson impeachment
days and then they said if you don't
turn over the evidence in during that
period you're obstructing Congress well
president Trump went to court to
challenge the his assess the necessity
of handing over that material both Bill
Clinton and Richard Nixon were allowed
to go all the way to the Supreme Court
where they ultimately lost Nixon resigns
soon afterwards my concern is that this
this really does seem like you are
making an appeal to the court into a
high crime or misdemeanor well you did
say that you didn't think they had
enough evidence that you thought that
the impeachment was wrought was rushed
why does the Democrats timeline matter
well it matters because the Democrats
know that this will fail this record is
incomplete
it has conflicts the only way that you
could convict the President on this
record is to literally make every
inference against his position and
that's basically white like Oh
my co witnesses said is that you can
base this on inferences the problem is
there's direct evidence out there the
house never subpoenaed Joe John Bolton
they never subpoenaed Mike Mulvaney they
never subpoenaed Giuliani these are
people with direct and for information
and they burned for months that they
could have gone to court to compel this
testimony that's a dangerous record to
impeach a president on because it's
easily manufactured against any
president Kim the president refuses to
participate in this inquiry does that
undermine his complaints about lack of
due process
sure and people I think rightly compare
what's happening here to an indictment
that comes out of a grand jury so a
grand jury meets secretly the
prosecutors present evidence and that
produces a charging document that could
send regular people like you or me to
jail or even to the electric chair it's
quite a serious consequence here the
President of the United States has an
opportunity to call witnesses to cut
bring his lawyers before the equivalent
of the grand jury before the House
Judiciary Committee in advance of
actually issuing the articles of
impeachment and he said I don't want to
participate in that so the at the end of
the day what we're talking about here
with this president is keeping his job
of course it's an important job it's one
that people that you know we elected him
on but but it's not the same as going to
jail Jonathan the president called you a
liberal law professor I don't think he
meant it as a compliment can you just
tell me what you thought about that
this isn't his letter to Pelosi I won't
associate myself with that single line
of the letter I but he wanted to create
an a double record he did with that
letter all right and you're in the
letter thank you Jed of course we should
point out thank you both that we should
point out the Democrats say they have to
go at this pace with impeachment because
there is an election coming and the
court system would take a long time the
abuse of power charge could influence
this vote that's what their timetable
response is Jonathan and Kim thank you
very much we always appreciate it CBS
News will bring you a special report
later this morning on this historic
house debate on the vote to impeach
President Trump